before I dive into the mechanics of how
cells divide I think it could be useful
to talk a little bit about a lot of the
vocabulary that surrounds DNA there's a
lot of words and some of them kind of
sound like each other but they can be
very confusing so the first few I'd like
to talk about is just about how DNA
either generates more DNA makes copies
of itself or how it essentially makes
proteins and we've talked about this in
the in the DNA and the DNA video so
let's say I have a little I'm just gonna
draw a small section of DNA say a van a
G T let's say I have two T's I have and
then I have 2 C's just some small
section it keeps going and of course
it's a double helix it has its
corresponding basis let me do that in
this color
so a corresponds to T G with C it forms
hydrogen bonds with C T with a T with AC
with G C with G and then of course it
just keeps going on in that direction so
there's a couple of different processes
that this DNA has to do one is when
you're just dealing with your body cells
and you need to make more versions of
let's say your skin cells your DNA has
to copy itself and this process is
called replication you're replicating
the DNA so let me do replication so how
can this DNA copy itself and this is one
of the beautiful things about how DNA is
structured replication so I'm doing a
gross oversimplification but the idea is
these two strands separate and then it
doesn't happen on its own it's
facilitated by a bunch of proteins and
enzymes but I'll talk about that the
details of the microbiology in a future
video so let me make separate so these
guys separate from each other let me put
it up here they separate from each other
and let me do take the other guy now too
big
the guide looks something like that they
separate from each other and then once
they've separated each other what could
happen let me delete some of that stuff
over here delete that stuff right there
so you have these this double helix they
were all connected their base pairs now
they separate from each other now once
they separate what can each of these do
they can now become the template for
each other so now I can form a if this
guy sitting by himself now a sudden a
thymine base might come and join right
here and so you could have these
nucleotides will start lining up so
you'll have a thymine and a cytosine and
then an adenine adenine guanine guanine
and it'll keep happening and then on
this other part that was formerly this
other green strand that was formerly
attached to this blue strand the same
thing will happen you have an adenine a
guanine thymine thymine cytosine
cytosine so what just happened by
separating and then just attracting
their complementary bases we just
duplicated this molecule all right and
I'll go more will do the microbiology of
it in the future but this is just to get
the idea this this is how the DNA makes
copies of itself and especially when we
talk about when we talk about mitosis
and meiosis I might say oh this is the
stage where the replication has occurred
now the other thing that you'll hear a
lot and I talked about this in the in
the DNA video is transcription
transcription in the DNA video I didn't
focus much on how does DNA duplicate
itself but one of the beautiful things
about this double helix design is that
it really is that easy to duplicate
itself you just split the two strips the
true HeLa C's and then they essentially
become a template for the other one and
then you have a duplicate now
transcription is what needs to occur for
this DNA eventually to turn into
proteins but transcription is the
intermediate step it's the step where
you go from DNA DNA to mRNA and then
that mRNA leaves the nucleus of the cell
and goes out to the ribosomes and I'll
talk about in that I'll talk about that
in a second so we could do the same
thing so this guy once again during
transcription will also split apart
so that was one split there and then the
other split is right there but instead
of and maybe actually maybe it makes
more sense just to do one half of it so
let me delete that so let's say just the
green this is the quoting let's say that
we're just going to transcribe the green
side right here let me erase all of this
stuff right now
wrong color erase this stuff right here
now what happens is instead of D instead
of instead of having deoxyribonucleic
acid nucleotides pair up with this DNA
strand you have ribonucleic acid or RNA
pair up with this and I'll do RNA in
magenta and so the RNA will pair up with
it and so thymine on the DNA side will
pair up with adenine guanine now with
when we talk about RNA instead of
thymine we have uracil uracil cytosine
cytosine and it just keeps going this is
mRNA M R na now what's this and then
this separates that mRNA separates and
it leaves the nucleus it leaves the
nucleus and then you have and then you
have translation translation translation
that is going from the mRNA to you
remember in the DNA video I little T in
a tRNA the transfer RNA kind of were the
trucks that drove up the amino acids to
the mRNA and this all occurs inside
these parts of the cell called the
ribosome but the translation is
essentially going from the mRNA RNA to
the proteins to the proteins and we saw
how that happened you have this guy let
me make a copy here this guy separates
let me actually copy the whole thing
this guy
separates leaves the nucleus and then
I'll delete this stuff and then you had
those little tRNA trucks that
essentially drive up so you know maybe
have some tRNA try an adenine guanine
guanine
this is tRNA that's a codon a codon is
three base pairs and attached to it it
has some amino acid and then you have
some other piece of tRNA let's say it's
a uracil cytosine adenine and attached
to that it has a different amino acid it
has a different amino acid this occurs
in the rub and then the amino acids
attached to each other and then they
form this long chain of amino acids
which is a protein so just to summarize
and the proteins form these weird and
complicated shapes so just just just to
kind of make sure you understand also if
we start with DNA and we're essentially
making copies of DNA
this is replication you're replicating
the DNA replication now if you're
starting with DNA and you are creating
mRNA from the DNA template
this is transcription transcription
trans description you're you're
transcribing the information from one
form to another transcription now when
the mRNA leaves the nucleus of the cell
and I've talked to let me just draw a
cell just to hit the point home you know
if this is the whole cell and we'll do
the we'll do the structure of a cell in
the future that's the whole cell the
nucleus is the center that's where all
the DNA is sitting in there and all of
the the replication and the
transcription occurs in here but then
the mRNA leaves the cell and then inside
the ribosomes which we'll talk about
more in the future
you have translation occur and the
proteins get formed so mRNA to protein
to protein is translation you're
translating from the genetic code so to
speak to the protein code so this is
translation
translation so these are just good words
to make sure you get clear and use them
very make sure you you're using the
right word when you're talking about the
different processes now the other part
of the vocabulary of DNA which when I
first learned it I found tremendously
confusing are the words chromosome I'll
write them down here because you can
already appreciate how confusing they
are chromosome chromosome chromatin
chromatin and chromatid chromatid so a
chromosome is we already talked about
you know you can have DNA you can have a
strand of DNA it's a double helix maybe
I'll you know this strand if I were to
zoom in it's actually two different HeLa
C's and of course they have their base
pairs joined up I'll just draw some base
pairs joined up like that so I want to
be clear when I draw this little green
line here it's actually a double helix
now that double helix gets wrapped
around proteins that are called histones
that double helix gets wrapped around
proteins that are called histones so
let's say it's wrapped like there and it
gets wrapped around like that and gets
wrapped around like that and you have
here these things called histones which
are these proteins this these proteins
now this structure when you talk about
the DNA as it is wrapped or that when
you talk about the DNA in combat 8 in in
combination with the proteins that kind
of give it structure and then these
proteins are actually wrapped around
more and more and eventually depending
on what stage we are in the cell's life
you have different structures but when
you talk about the the the nucleic acid
which is the DNA and you combine that
with the proteins you're talking about
the chromatin chromatin so this is DNA
plus you can view the structural
proteins that give the DNA its shape
structural proteins and the idea
chromatin was first used because when
people look at a cell every time I've
drawn the cell nucleus
so far I've drawn these very
well-defined I'll use words let's say
this is a cell's nucleus I've been
drawing very well-defined
structures here so that's one and then
this could be another one we've two
shorter and then it has its homologous
chromosome so I've been drawing these
chromosomes right and each of these
chromosomes I did in the last video are
essentially these really long structures
of DNA long chains of DNA kind of
wrapped tightly around each other so
when I drew it like that if we zoomed in
you'd see one strand and it's really
just wrapped around itself like this and
then it's homologous chromosome and
remember in the variation video I talked
about the homologous chromosome
essentially codes for the same genes but
it has a different version and it came
from if the blue came from the dad the
red came from the mom but it's coding
for essentially the same genes so when
we talk about when we talk about this
one chain let's say this one chain that
I got from my dad of DNA in this
structure we refer to that as a
chromosome chromosome now it would if we
refer generally and I want to be clear
here DNA only takes the shape at certain
stages of its life when it's when it's
actually when it's actually replicating
itself when not when it's replicating
when the cell is dividing DNA before the
cell can divide DNA picks this very
well-defined shape most of the cell's
life when the DNA is actually doing its
work when it's actually creating
proteins or proteins are being
essentially transcribed and translated
from the DNA the DNA isn't all bundled
up like this because if it was bundled
up like this would be very hard for kind
of the replication and the and the and
the transcription met up kind of a
machinery to get onto the DNA and make
the proteins and do whatever else
normally DNA let me draw that same
nucleus normally you can't even you
can't even it's not even you can't even
see it with a with a normal light
microscope it's it's it's so thin that
the DNA strand is just completely
separated around the cell I mean I'm
drawing it here so you can drive maybe
the other one is like this
all right and then you have that shorter
strand that's like this and so it's all
you can't even see it it's not in this
well-defined structure this is the way
it normally is and then you have the
other short strand it's like this so you
would just see this kind of big mess of
a combination of DNA and proteins and
this is what people essentially referred
to as chromatin chromatin so the words
it can be very ambiguous and very
confusing but the general usage is when
you're talking about the well-defined
one chain of DNA in this kind of
well-defined structure that is a
chromosome chromatin can either refer to
kind of the structure of the chromosome
the the combination of the DNA and the
proteins that give the structure or it
can refer to this whole mess of multiple
chromosomes and DNA which of which mido
you have all this DNA for multiple
chromosomes and all the proteins all
jumbled together so I just want to make
that clear now then the next word is
well what does this chromatid thing
what is this chromatid thing actually
just in case I didn't I don't remember
if I label these these proteins that
give structure to the chromatin or that
make up the chromatin or give structure
to the chromosome they're called
histones histones and they're multiple
types that give structure at different
levels and we'll do that in more detail
so what's a chromatid so after when DNA
replicates so let's say that let's say
that this was my DNA before right when
it's just in this normal state I have
one version from my dad one version from
my mom now let's say it replicates so my
version from my dad at first it's like
this it's a big strand of DNA it creates
another version of itself that is
identical if the machinery worked
properly and that so that identical
piece will look like this and they
actually are initially attached to each
other they're attached to each other at
a point called the centromere centromere
now even though I have two strands here
they're now attached and when I have
these two strands that are contained the
exact still have this strand right here
and then I have well let me actually
draw it a different way I could draw it
multiple different ways I could draw I
can say this is one strand here and then
I have another strand I have another
strand here now I have two copies that
can they they're coding for the exact
same DNA they are identical I still call
this a chromosome I still call this a
chromosome chromosome this this whole
thing is still called a chromosome but
now each individual copy is called a
chromatid so that's one chromatid
chromatid and this is another chromatid
sometimes I'll call them sister
chromatids maybe they should call them
twin chromatids because they have the
same genetic information chromatid so
this chromosome has two chromatids now
before the replication occurred or the
DNA replicated itself you could say that
this chromosome right here this
chromosome like your father has one
chromatid you could call it a chromatid
although that's tends to not be the
convention people start talking about
chromatids once you have two of them in
a chromosome and we'll learn in mitosis
and meiosis these two chromatids
separate and once they separate that
same strand of DNA that you once called
a chromatid you now call them
individually chromosomes so that's one
of them and then you have another one
that maybe gets separated in this
direction let me make that you know
circle that one with the green so this
one might move away like that and the
one that I circled in the orange might
move away like this now once they
separate and they're no longer connected
by the centromere now what we originally
called as one chromosome with two
chromatids you will now refer to as two
separate chromosomes or you could say
now you have two separate chromosomes
each made up of one chromatid so
hopefully that clears up a little bit
some of this jargon around DNA I always
found it quite confusing but it'll be a
useful tool when we start going into
mitosis and meiosis and I start saying
oh the chromosomes become chromatids and
it's like wait how did one chromosome
become two chromosomes and you know how
did a chromatid become a chromosome and
it's all just revolves around the vocab
and I would have picked different
vocabulary then you know calling this a
chromosome and then calling each of
these individually chromosomes but
that's the way we have decided to name
them actually just so in case you're
curious you probably think where does
this word chromo come and if your old
Kodak film it's called chroma color and
chromo is essentially relates to color
and I think it comes from the Greek word
actually for color and then it got that
word because when we people first
started looking in the nucleus of cell
they would apply dye and these things
that we call chromosomes would take up
the dye so that you could see it well
with a light microscope so that's why
and so them comes from soma for body so
you could kind of view it as colored
body so that's why they call it a
chromosome so chromatids chromatin also
will take up well I won't go into all of
that as well but hopefully that clears a
little bit this whole chromatid
chromosome chromatin debate and well
we're well equipped now to study mitosis
and meiosis